et malgré l'annexion de la région de
Donets revendiquée par les Russes les
troupes ukrainiennes continuent là aussi
de gagner du terrain notre envoyé
spécial Mélina Huet se trouve à
drouchkifca qu'en est-il du moral des
soldats Ukrainiens dans cette région on
écoute ses précisions
le moral est bon voire très bon en tout
cas sur les réseaux sociaux en Ukraine
depuis plusieurs jours se multiplient
des vidéos où l'on voit des soldats
Ukrainiens qui dansent qui chantent à la
faveur de ses avancées de ces percées de
ses reprises de territoire des drapeaux
Ukrainiens bleu et jaune qui pullulent
un peu partout dans des municipalités
qui ont été occupées pendant des
semaines voire des mois mais tout cela
évidemment c'est c'est ta relativiser
encore une fois pourquoi parce que les
villages ou les villes qui sont reprises
par les Ukrainiens ne sont plus que
désolation des endroits où il n'y a plus
ni électricité ni gaz ni au courante des
populations qui sont éreintées qui sont
durablement affectés par la guerre qui
n'en peuvent tout simplement plus et les
soldats et bien ça les affecte hier nous
parlions à un soldat qui est mobilisé
ici dans l'aublast de deniès dans l'est
de l'Ukraine et quand on lui demandait
comment lui il se sentait le disait
écoutez ni bien ni mal en réalité et
bien c'est ses moyens ses moyens
pourquoi parce que
ce qu'il voit c'est également de
nombreux hommes dans leur rang qui
perdent de la vie et ça évidemment c'est
quelque chose dont on parle un petit peu
moins en Ukraine en ce moment